last week big news anthony hopkins and
jonathan pryce both got oscar
nominations for the movie the two popes
yeah it's the story of how Pope Benedict
stepped down and Pope Francis took over
well the two popes has been an audience
favorite around the world and that got
me thinking okay this would make a
fantastic Broadway musical yes thank you
thank you yeah thank you yeah here's
what I did I purchased last week I
purchased the musical rights to the two
popes yeah no one else was bidding on it
I was able to get it for $1,500
I want to show you an excerpt from our
production we open in New Haven next
week because I am moving fast ladies and
gentleman you the first to see it and
you're welcome please welcome to Pope's
[Applause]
[Music]
don't vant to be pop no more don't want
to be poked no more
now there's the panic in the Vatican
looking for the man who can't repay sin
at the table Cardinal bergoglio nd Solon
broadly of changing name - Francis and
take over the shop we used to go round
and teach me the ropes yes we can have
two
[Music]
[Applause]
to go community coming soon
very excited about this we got a great
show tonight
fantastic show from the CBS series their
co-workers dark ages Steve Buscemi
[Applause]
[Music]